in an Xbox golden seal of quality where
they only hitting 85 Plus on Metacritic
and they're dropping three to five of
these games per year I'm sure that I'm
sure they love that I'm with all that
right there what else you got then we
got Hollywood rules $5 super chat about
to jump into Championship Sunday wishing
K good luck on his ners brother salute
got to root for Detroit being a fellow
have not Jets
fan that's pain I feel that Herman Mo
Barry
Sanders with them I Ain got no beef with
the Lions I understand I understand I
understand there's been no greatness on
the Lions I get it GG's GG got hey dirt
TTS shout out yo what's up bro salot
what else we got that's it we caught up
all right let's get into first all right
all right here we go so this the big one